president biden's chief medical advisor
dr anthony fauci joins us now to discuss
good morning to you dr fauci it's good
to see you we just heard in david's
piece how students say that they will
now get the vaccine because it has now
been fda approved how much of a game
changer do you think that this will be
well i think it's going to be very
important from three standpoints gail
when you have a vaccine that's fully
approved by the fda there are a certain
percentage of unvaccinated but eligible
to be vaccinated people
who have in a survey said about 30
percent of them who were reluctant to
get vaccinated now will go ahead and get
vaccinated so that's a pretty good chunk
dr fauci how far away do you think we
are from full approval for modern and
johnson johnson
i don't think it's too far away because
both of those products were a bit behind
in the initiation of their euas
and then in the submission obviously of
a lot of material that is required for a
bla so i think it's a temporal issue i
don't think there's anything different
necessarily about the process is just
that they submitted or are submitting
their material a bit later we're talking
about after pfizer did are we talking
about weeks do you think months still
you know it's difficult to predict
because the issues may come up with the
fda i would imagine
knowing the differences in times of the
submission of their eua
that it likely would be a matter of a
month or so but not a lot more than that
dr fauci how close with this approval
and the two other approvals that are
likely to be forthcoming soon how close
are we to getting back to some sense of
normalcy where there are fewer
guidelines and we don't think about the
coronavirus on a daily basis
you know that's going to be up to us and
when i say up to us i mean it's really
how many people get vaccinated how many
people step up and say you know we've
had enough of this we've got to put an
end to this terrible outbreak that's
completely disrupted our lives what is
that so we have the vaccines available
you know the threshold is something that
we don't know and the reason i say we
don't know it is because you have to get
to a situation like with measles where
you were like way 90 plus percent of
people were vaccinated and really got
that kind of what we call herd immunity
you know what that number is because
when it gets below that number you start
to see outbreaks like we saw some time
ago in the new york city area with
acidic jewish people who were not
getting vaccinated but right now if
you've never been there you don't know
whether that's 80 85 90 you just don't
know and when you don't know
the thing to do
is to just do whatever you can
to get as many people vaccinated as you
can and when you reach that point you'll
know it because you won't have any
infections but you really can't
accurately predict what that number is
let's go back dr fauci to the stepping
up part you know because if more people
got the vaccine we would be out of this
much sooner you know the science has
shown that and i heard you say that if
people get it we could maybe get back to
normal in spring of uh 2022.
so what do you say to people who think
this fda process was rushed you know
that how do we know that this is safe
can you just hit on that a second and
how did you come up with spring of 2022
yeah
well let me answer your first question
first of all gail it wasn't rushed they
did they meticulously went over every
bit of data
spring of 2022 is just an estimate gail
it means that if we can get a large
majority overwhelming majority of the
people vaccinated and we get through the
winter okay because remember we're going
to have the complication of influenza
and other respiratory illnesses if we
can get through the winter okay and we
can get those people vaccinated that 80
million or so who are not vaccinated i
estimate and it's purely an estimate
that by the time we get to the spring
and people come outdoors again as
opposed to being inside i believe that
we can get to some degree of normality
that approximates what we'd like to be
but it's up to us gail all right dr
fauci we thank you for the message step
up people we hear you thank you very
much
thank you for having me